this video is brought to you by the
Rijksmuseum spikes tube after this video
check out their channel by hitting the
link in the description what's up
wisecrack Helen here to talk about Huey
Lewis's number one fan you like Huey
Lewis on the news I think that's all
he's really known for American Psycho
has always been a lightning rod for
controversy the book by Bret Easton
Ellis was infamously scrapped by its
initial publisher amidst uproar over its
depictions of violence so it's not
surprising that the film version
released nine years after the book's
publication has become similarly
controversial now this video will be
focused on the more controversial
aspects of the film not the book sure
some of these points made of tail with
Ellis's novel but for the purposes here
in everything we state just applies to
the movie most of the controversy
surrounding American Psycho stems from
how people perceive it is the film a
critique on the consumerism and
superficiality of 80s yuppie culture or
does the film's exes actually glorify
this lifestyle and what to make of the
film's violence particularly towards
women some proclaim American Psycho of
feminist masterpiece while others have
labeled it misogynistic so which is it
further what exactly are we supposed to
make of Patrick Bateman antihero villain
or none of the above let's find out in
this wisecrack edition on American
Psycho deeper dump and of course
spoilers ahead alright guys first a
quick recap American Psycho is set in
1988 the heyday of the rich yuppie Wall
Streeter Patrick Bateman fits this
stereotype to a tee he's a handsome
wealthy businessman way more obsessed
with dining at the trendiest restaurants
than in well actually working Batemans
life is all artifice on the surface he
has a beautiful fiance and a close-knit
group of friends but take a little
deeper and you see he actually hates
them all not only that but as a side
hustle
Patrick murders homeless men and
prostitutes Patrick's world begins to
crumble soon after he brutally murders a
business rival Paul Allen and a
detective begins to look at him as a
suspect the line between reality and
fantasy blurs as Patrick descends into
madness and goes on a gory killing spree
however despite murdering dozens of
people nobody seems to care in fact
there are seemingly no bodies and when
Patrick does confess to Paul Allen's
murder he's told Paul's still alive I
had dinner with Paul Helen twice in
London just ten days ago so what gives
did Patrick actually kill anybody was it
all in his head
or does it even matter American Psycho
satirizes the shallow consumer lifestyle
of the 1980s the film revels in excess
from the extravagant dinners and grilled
free-range rabbit with french fries to
bateman's over indulgent morning routine
I believe in taking care of myself in a
balanced diet in a rigorous exercise
routine in the morning if my face is a
little puffy I'll put on an ice pack
while doing my stomach crunches
Patrick's obsessed with his status among
the wealthy Wall Streeters whether it be
his ability to procure a reservation at
Dorsia
the hippest restaurant of the moment yes
I know it's a little late but is it
possible to reserve a table for two at
8:00 or 8:30 perhaps or his grooming
it's no coincidence that Bateman
repeatedly references the Trump name
Ivana Trump in the 80s Trump was
synonymous with excess he was the
ultimate yuppie a billionaire Wall
Street business tycoon with a bombshell
wife and $10,000 suit just to give him
Trump himself when asked for a 1987
Newsweek article whether he was the
ultimate yuppie Trump responded rather
succinctly yeah maybe or take this
description of his 1985 apartment in
Architectural Digest every surface of
the home shimmers like liquid gold
covered with fabric painted in 24 karat
gold in the goldleaf ceilings and in the
crystal chandeliers and candlesticks
throughout the dining room shimmers with
Tiffany's glassware resting on a
mahogany table embellished with strips
of gold leaf the dining chairs are from
donia furniture and the alexander
lieberman composition is titled gate 26
similarly Patrick Bateman is focused on
the minutia that defines his elite
status
is bedsheets out of the question I can
only get these at his skincare routine I
use a deep Pore Cleanser lotion in the
shower I use a water activated gel
cleanser and on the face an exfoliating
gel scrub and his business cards mostly
his business cards let's take a quick
moment to give props to Christian Bale's
performance
this really is an acting showcase for
the ages bill takes absurdity and turns
it into high drama just look at how I
reacts to something as trivial as a
business cards font somehow making
Helvetica feel like the end of the world
I can't believe that Bryce prefers van
Patten's card to mine
bale nails the satirical toned the film
at once showcasing how nonsensical this
minutia is yet also making it sadly
believable that this could be so
important to a status conscious yuppie
everything in Patrick Bateman's life is
commodified and rated uses tokens of his
perceived superiority to others
American Psycho uses material objects to
comment on the superficiality of its
characters everyone in the film is vapid
and self-absorbed
way more concerned with how they look
and how others perceive them then in the
actual conflicts happening in their
periphery the film is punctuated with
dinner conversations about the state of
the world well what about the massacres
in Sri Lanka honey when price mentions
the genocide in Sri Lanka bateman 1ups
him stating the real issue they should
all be worried about is oh we hafta
end apartheid for one and slow down the
nuclear arms race stop terrorism and
world hunger we have to provide food and
shelter for the homeless an opposed
racial discrimination and promotes civil
rights while also promoting equal rights
for women we have to encourage a return
to traditional moral values most
importantly we have to promote general
social concern but Patrick is only
interested in using these real-world
problems as a form of one-upsmanship to
prove he's better than price when
actually confronted by a homeless person
Bateman doesn't provide him with food or
shelter or money he just brutally stabs
him later when price asks Patrick what
he thinks about the iran-contra scandal
babe mere reveals his true feelings
about these worldly conflicts whatever
patrick is often mistaken for other
people Paul mistakes Patrick for another
business associate great fan Marcus and
later Patrick's lawyer thinks he's
someone named Davis by the way Davis
House India this highlights the artifice
of Patrick and his friends lifestyle in
a society preoccupied with acquiring
goods at all cost
nobody cares much about any of the other
people around them everybody's the same
and completely interchangeable all that
really matters is the suits and jewels
they wear the yachts they party on and
the restaurants they dine in an American
Psycho class is a competition a sport
reflective of Thorne steam Veblen's
theories on what he calls the leisure
class particularly conspicuous
consumption / Veblen conspicuous
consumption is the consumption of goods
as an evidence of pecuniary strength it
is a means of repute ability to the
gentleman of leisure basically to prove
you're better than everybody else you
have to show it be it a larger house
fancier clothes or shinier bling
similarly Patrick Bateman always defines
himself in relation to others he hates
Paul Helen because he can get into
fancier restaurants and his business
card is nicer on the other hand
Patrick thinks he's better than his
doppelganger Marcus because he has a
slightly better haircut
Patrick's intent on proving his
superiority lecturing lower-class
prostitutes on the meaning behind
Genesis and Whitney Houston Surat
been a big Genesis fan ever since the
release of their 1980 album the fact
that he takes such pride in trivial
knowledge is in itself the point
Bateman flaunts his wealth and knowledge
to prove that he's better than others
according to Babylon much of this is
inherited from our more primitive past
the lower status people did all the
productive work well the higher status
people were test with the honorable
duties of hunting and killing far less
productive behaviors been saying farming
as if a nod to Veblen nathan uses his
prestige to be both incredibly
unproductive but also take up the hobby
of murder the film goes on to suggest
that beneath Patrick's need for fancy
suits in a better apartment lies a
literal bloodlust consumer capitalism as
an actual bloodsport Batemans murderous
inclinations are presented as the truth
lurking beneath the facade of his
superficial lifestyle at the start of
the film patrick comments that there is
nothing to him he's just a shell of a
person there is an idea of a Patrick
Bateman some kind of abstraction but
there is no real me only an entity
something illusory and though I can hide
my cold gaze and you can shake my hand
and feel flesh gripping yours and maybe
you can even sense our lifestyles are
probably comparable I simply am not yet
by the end after Patrick has succumbed
to murdering people giving in to his
baser desires he becomes whole no I mean
I'm in touch with humanity by
acknowledging his need for money only
hides his baser desire to kill Patrick
is self actualized I'll be it as a
serial killer ostensibly
American Psycho signifies that the true
nature of the consumer capitalist is
well a cold-blooded serial killer
so what seemed that this is obviously a
deep film but despite being a savage
critique on consumerism people still
can't help themselves there's something
undeniably seductive about Patrick
Bateman the Patrick Bateman lifestyle is
pervasive in our culture mr. Porter a
clothing store put out a whole line
based on dressing just like Patrick
Bateman there are articles on how to
replicate Patrick Bateman's grooming
style looking back at the restaurants he
dined at and where he would dine today
there's even a video that gives you a 3d
tour of Batemans apartment so why are
people so infatuated with Patrick
Bateman despite the fact that he's a
deranged murderer well parody seems to
have a tendency to offer competing
interpretations of the thing 'it
parodies it both legitimizes and
subverts its subject and American Psycho
for all its subversive merits does revel
in excess I mean Patrick is handsome
good with the ladies has a beautiful
apartment a well-paying job who wouldn't
want that lifestyle
Plus American Psycho often plays
Patrick's more monstrous acts as comedic
or just cuts away from them entirely
when Patrick kills Paul Allen it's
played his comedy score too Huey Lewis
in the news and when Patrick murders
Christine we only see the net result a
chainsaw has pierced her body but we
don't see the moment of impact the film
may bascomb Batemans excessive lifestyle
but never his murderous inclinations
allowing the audience to identify more
with the glitz and glamour and letting
him off the hook for his more gruesome
misdeeds
so by indulging in Batemans lifestyle at
the expense of his violence his American
Psycho undermining its own satirical
depth furthermore many accused the
violence in American Psycho as being
explicitly targeted towards women and
the lower-class glorifying their
grotesque deaths
nobody even really cares about all the
women Patrick killed it's only Paul
Allen that detective Kimball is
concerned about but is this the point
the film is actually trying to make in a
2015 interview with dayz screenwriters
one of your jurors said I very much
think American Psycho is a feminist film
it's a satire about how men compete with
each other and how in this hyper-real
universe we created women are even less
important than your tan or your suit or
where you summer and to me even though
the women are all sort of tragic
it's about how men perceive and treat
them director mary harron reiterates
this point stating American Psycho is a
great parody of masculinity
it's a send-up it was accused of being
sexist but to me it was always an attack
and satire of sexism and of male ego to
this point the film showcases the
cavalier attitudes many men have for
women there are no girls with good
personalities patric lords over women's
bodies as if he owns them at the
workplace Patrick tells his assistant
what to wear and then in bed he pays
women to do was he instructs Patrick
feels that he can do as he pleases with
a woman's body including killing
mutilating and even eating them what's
more he thinks he can get away with it
and the cold cynical truth American
Psycho presents is that Patrick's right
he can and does get away with it so yes
American Psycho satirizes male ego and
consumer society which would make it
inherently deep get the net result of
the film's impact seems to be upholding
the surface value lifestyle but it reels
against making it perhaps not domed but
a failure nonetheless Patrick Bateman
despite his monstrous acts is still
lotted as an anti-establishment antihero
but in a metatextual turn this may
actually be what the film is about
Patrick Bateman constantly tells other
people he's a murderer to which either
they miss hear him I mean to
murders and executions mostly do you
like it depends why most guys I know who
work in mergers and acquisitions really
don't well just dismiss the confession
as a joke
you get my message Jesus yes that was
hilarious
just as Patrick Bateman confesses his
crimes and everyone thinks he's joking
or just misinterprets him
American Psycho the film has been either
misinterpreted as misogynistic and
pro-consumer or has been treated as a
joke and a parody yet the issues
American Psycho rails against a status
obsessed society sexism and wealth
inequality still remained just as
relevant today as they were in the 90s
and early 2000s it's just as Patrick
Bateman says at the end of the film this
confession has meant nothing
likewise American Psycho cynically and
truthfully ridicules a society run amok
but knows deep down that this confession
too will mean nothing so we're gonna
give the film as deep even though it too
probably doesn't matter thanks to all
our patrons don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and before you go I
want to give a shout out to the
Rijksmuseum similar to wisecrack Reich's
to Biff the rice museums YouTube channel
explores pop culture and media their
series is this art discusses what counts
as art from Tarantino films and CGI
sequences to memes in the Kardashians
they have films that look at everything
going on in our society today through an
artistic and analytical lens their
latest video examines the rather
fascinating evolution of political
cartoons which in case you didn't know
have been around in one form or another
since antiquity
while memes may occasionally set Twitter
on fire that's nothing compared to what
a series of political cartoons did to
the DeWitt brothers back in 1670 to talk
about canceled culture go watch the
video to see what I'm talking about and
prepare for a binge because the stuff on
Reich's tube is seriously addicting so
head on over subscribe and let him know
wisecrack Sencha thanks for watching
guys
[Music]